hello today i'm having an interview
about the topic of sparse experts now
ironically the people are absolute
experts in this type of models these
models they are huge they're usually
language models but they don't have to
be they're usually transformers but they
don't have to be what they do have in
common is this notion of sparse experts
these models go up to the trillions of
parameters and they achieve this via
sparsity now i want to do a very very
brief introduction of what sparse expert
models are and then we'll dive into the
interview right away because i don't
want to keep it from you so let's look
at a transformer model usually i have
some sort of an input
that is tokens a sequence of tokens
which are represented here by circles
and what i'm going to do with these
tokens is i'm going to alternatingly
push them through different layers now
one big layer type that is common in
transformers is the attention layer
we're not going to talk about the
attention layer today all you have to
know is that it takes in a sequence of
tokens and it outputs a sequence of
tokens again ideally the same amount as
went in which i failed to draw here the
other very common big type of layer in
these transformers is what's called the
feed forward layer now the feed forward
layer is just a linear layer and every
token goes through this linear layer by
itself so every token individually goes
through the same transformation and thus
as we do this with all tokens again we
end up with a sequence of as many tokens
as we input now a sparse expert model
isn't very different than this the
attention layers commonly aren't really
touched so that works just the same
however in the feed forward layer we see
a big difference notably we don't only
have one feet forward layer we have many
so here is feet forward one here is feet
forward two
here is feet forward three and here is
feed forward four each one representing
a different individual linear
transformation of a token now when we
talk about sparse experts these things
here are called the experts they're
called the experts because they're
thought to specialize in very specific
tasks and the goal in sparse expert
models is to route the tokens to the
corresponding correct experts so every
token goes through what's known as a
routing function we're going to talk
about this routing function in the
interview but in essence it is a very
simple usually something like a linear
function or a simple transformation that
decides to which of the experts any
given token is routed so sometimes even
in sparse expert models a token is
routed to multiple experts but in the
newest iterations the tokens are simply
routed to one single experts and none of
the other usually this is done as i said
by some sort of a linear transformation
followed by a softmax to decide where
the token goes so every token would be
assigned to one expert and that gives
the possibility of scaling these models
up dramatically not only do you save a
lot of compute because the tokens only
go to one place ergo you only need to
compute that one thing for that
particular token but also there's the
opportunity to massively shard and
parallelize these different experts
across different machines as you only
need to route the token to one place
that means you dramatically reduce these
big all to all reductions they still
happen but not as much so as i already
said the biggest models have trillions
of parameters you need to take a little
bit of care of how you then aggregate
the tokens once they come out of the
experts so essentially what you want to
do is you want to carry over the
likelihood from the routing function up
here but this is a minor detail a minor
details are important but you know so i
know it doesn't look like much but these
sparse expert models really have the
potential to massively scale up our
current efforts in ai and i have no
doubt that they're going to play a role
in the near future when we're looking at
bigger and bigger models because at some
point the purely dense models will reach
sort of the limit of what's physically
doable and then it's a good opportunity
that we have models that can go even
larger alright so without further ado
let's jump into the interview i hope you
are enjoying yourself if you do have any
sort of comments please leave a comment
share the video around if you like it
and i'll see you around bye-bye
hello everyone my guests today are
william fedes and barret zoff who are
engineers and researchers at google
google brain and have been
diving into large models specifically
sparse expert models which are models
that well feature this notion of experts
and also have a notion of sparsity and
hopefully today we'll discover what this
is all about specifically we'll talk
broadly about three papers in a long
line of work one is the switch
transformers paper which was really i
believe one of the first papers that
just
had like massive amounts of parameter
was that like trillion probably trillion
parameters it it was big 1.6
that's right yeah yeah it's insane uh
and then there's there's glam which uh
demonstrated a really nice scaling laws
with these
uh sparse experts and more recently
there is designing
effective sparse expert models which as
far as i can see is also a bit of a of a
maybe a summary recommendations uh more
of a what we learned type of thing
um so william and barrett welcome to the
channel thanks so much for being here
yeah thanks for having me for having us
so can you give us just a little bit of
of context what you mean when you say
sparse expert models
um
yeah sure so this is a great question
especially since the word sparsity crops
up in like many different aspects of
deep learning whether it's you know like
sparse attention or you know various
other sparse paradigms um
so yeah sparsity in our case means that
each input can get different uh subsets
of parameters
so that that's kind of like the main
sparsity that we're talking about here
and it's like you know it's a very
natural concept right like normally
in like a dense transformer for example
you have you know a word embedding
and you know any word will have the same
parameters and compute applied to it
and in sparse models typically what
happens is you have the same amount of
compute but you can have different
subsets of the model parameters be like
you know acting on the model inputs and
what does that mean in in practice so
we're we're talking mainly about let's
say transformer models here no is that a
good characterization of things or do
you do you see sparse expert models in a
more general sense
yeah i mean these things actually almost
sort of like cropped up originally as
almost like in the context of like
ensemble type methods where you have a
bunch of like almost like fully
independent models um and then you're
sort of using these as like you know
each model is an expert but the common
paradigm as of like 2022 is sort of
experts as a layer um so this is like
really popularized by gnome shazier's
work um in 2017 outrageously large
models and in that context they were
actually inserting it in between lstm
layers which is like the prevailing like
recurrent architecture at the time
most of the things just because like the
world has sort of shifted towards
transformers and it seems like almost
all modalities now um we're often
thinking about experts as a layer inside
transformers
typically we're sort of doing this at
the feed forward so these blocks that
just sort of independently apply on the
different like tokens but we've also
kind of considered it in self-attention
layers it's just sort of like a very
general concept but
yeah typically in transformers
so you have this notion of uh an expert
which you say is is sort of a
specialized function or something like
this and then there is often this thing
called a router how
how does
information find its way through these
experts what are the general principles
in that and
why would i even consider doing
something like this
yeah so great question
so yeah so you have this figure up here
and so one thing to note is that
basically if you only have a single
expert it essentially reduces to just a
normal dense transformer
so the interpretation is pretty natural
and in almost all of the ways people are
doing sparse expert models nowadays
there's some notion of a learned
mechanism that for you know
embedding at the current layer you
figure out what expert you should you
know send this representation to
um you know and this can be ranging from
you know very simple to just like you
know a simple soft max function over the
total number of experts to you know very
complicated you know linear programming
type solutions that have a more like
globally optimal
solution
so
yeah so this is this is kind of like the
paradigm and i think it's a pretty
natural one so even if you want to only
you know
[Music]
yeah apply
one set of weights per representation
now you have the option of just instead
of always applying the same weight
matrix now you can you know maybe have a
selection of in this figure four
different weight matrices
and the way that you know we've done
this in our work and i think is the most
common is it's just there's a single
feed forward network so you take your
input representation
and then you just you know apply it with
something that's going to be like you
know the model dimension by the number
of experts and then you apply like a
soft max function to get like a
probability over all of the different
experts in our switch transformer work
the routing was extremely simple where
it's just like you just send it to the
highest um
like the highest expert with the highest
probability
and then you know you just simply route
it to that expert
then the output of that computation gets
scaled by the router probability so if
it was like oh with 0.9 send it to
expert 2
then when you have the output of that
computation you scale it all by 0.9
do i remember correctly that there was
some paper that it was this an older
paper and this might be getting very
technical for a second but was there an
older paper that said something like you
always needed to send it to at least two
of these experts otherwise it's kind of
unstable is that an older paper or a
newer than yours
it actually wasn't um
instability that they were cautioning
against it was more this idea that
we're doing this like weird discretized
operation so
instead of using like reinforcement
learning to sort of like update on the
experts we're kind of doing this like
kind of hacky back propagation uh
through
these like soft max operations which
have been masked and the idea that top
two or greater was necessary because
they were thinking well i'm creating a
probability distribution for this token
for this word over the available experts
if i don't have at least two i can't
tell whether expert i or j was sort of
better for this one um
so it's like in order to have you know
the hypothesis was sort of like a useful
gradient signal for the router it has to
know well should i have sent it to i or
j
um and then we just sort of didn't
follow convention and did one and it
also seems to work just fine um i think
in part because you're sort of doing
this sort of normalization so you can
still get an up waiting or a down
waiting if you select um an expert so
it's like oh if that expert selection
uh worked out well for you or worked out
poorly for you you can then sort of
adjust the embedding for that expert and
then you at the next pass if you saw
that same token you're still doing this
like soft max distribution so you're
kind of like upgrading or downgrading it
so i think that's sort of like the gist
of the mechanism
and this this i think this idea was
at least from 2017 it may have predated
it
could you maybe
now that we're talking about history uh
trace the evolution of this line of
research a little bit you already
mentioned this existed as uh
sort of ensemble methods inside of it
i'm talking now specifically about uh
sparse experts within transformers which
are the things that allow us to really
scale up to these these giant models
what's the what's sort of the line of
research what are the original things
i'm to guess this this work is among
them and what were the improvements that
happened since then in this field great
joy are you go for liam
uh
yeah so i mean like going back 30 years
like you have like jordans and jacob um
this obviously predates transformer
because transformer was a 2017
development um so i mean the concept is
very very old um
i think it just kind of like resurged in
popularity i'd say like the first
yeah the very first sort of um use of
mixture of experts in transformer was
leptin at all in 2020 so this is g-shard
and it just showed really remarkable
improvements
in translation
what they were doing was you know
analogous to switch transforming these
other works is they just sort of
substitute these feed forward blocks
with experts and in that case sort of
also similar with switch transformer
they had many many experts um i think in
that case it was thousands and they were
showing really significant improvements
over state-of-the-art translation models
um i think as the field has sort of
evolved um as we've sort of like learned
a bit more about it
there seemed to be this like kind of
general trend of like okay cool we can
pre-train
these models or like in the case of
translation there's no big distribution
shift when you're
training to translate you're also doing
inference to translate um but in switch
transformer we found okay we'll
pre-train
to you know improve the perplexi improve
the prediction next token
and we were getting significant
improvements but then when we took it
under a data distribution shift to
fine-tuning it was performing quite
badly with many experts so i think
there's been this trend to
try to balance the computation and the
parameters a bit more so i think some of
the prevailing models have actually in
transformers have actually gone towards
fewer experts so 16 32 64 experts not
thousands of experts um so that's kind
of like the lineage of a mixture of
experts and then like mixture of experts
in the context of transformers
and what is so in that context
if
one expert is the classic transformer
model and that seems to not work as well
as many experts but too many don't work
what is the abstraction that i can think
of for an expert like what does an
expert learn what is an expert
responsible for approximately do you
have any idea what happens like what
what how does it make sense that the
optimal number is let's say a few dozen
and not super many but also not one
yeah so great question i so yeah there's
like a few parts to this so one like
i i think it's really just like an
empirical observation right now that you
know 16
versus 64 versus you know 2048 versus 10
000 um
you know like it seems like the expert
numbers in the middle like it's not from
the standpoint of like on a
purse that faces more experts typically
don't make things worse usually it's
like better or about the same but things
start to level off
but it's very inconvenient to have a lot
of experts because it's just this like a
huge memory footprint the way that the
models are distributed it's not really
amenable towards typically unless you
have like tons of you know
parallel cores going so like actually
the observation where you kind of want
to actually have
like a middle amount of experts is a lot
of the times actually driven by just the
like um practicality of then like
training serving these models um
yeah in terms of like what these models
are actually learning like intuitively
so we actually studied this in our most
recent work kind of looking at you know
each expert what are they specializing
in what are they learning
and interestingly they kind of
specialize in some shallow concepts
which you would think maybe there would
be like only really deep things going on
and it would be kind of hard to inspect
them but you know we noticed like oh
there's like a punctuation expert or an
expert that will you know
talk about you know like proper nouns
which which we thought was pretty funny
and maybe not super intuitive
for you know how yeah actually if you
want you could switch over to the recent
paper and we actually have a a figure
which sort of shows some of these things
so you can kind of like follow along and
see how shallow these things actually
are
yeah
yeah
so this this would be this would be diff
so you'd you found an expert or in this
case multiple experts that
that uh focused on
the these sort of things
so there's conjunctions punctuation verb
visual description which is which is
interesting because that's kind of
um
[Music]
i want to say like a higher level thing
than just the punctuation right
counting numbers yeah how do you make
sense of this stuff like
what's going on
i yeah i mean i think we were sort of
expecting maybe like a higher level of
description but like or like sort of
like representation
um
it's i i think we've just started
started to sort of like crack and like
look into these models to actually see
what's going on um that obviously like
one big specialization that you're
seeing here are these sentinel tokens um
to make sense of that we were sort of
doing pre-training where it sort of fill
in the blank tests and a blank is sort
of represented by uh
these like little sentinels so like
extra id10 represents like you know the
blank temp
and we often really frequently see um
experts sort of specializing on these
blanks um
so that's sort of an interesting thing
and then i think that also might segue
into maybe you want to actually
given this sort of like you know
observed specialization maybe you
actually want to make some experts um
higher capacity or give them more
compute to sort of do things that might
be harder um but honestly i mean this is
still very early um it'd be interesting
for sort of like you know some of the
interpretability lens that like
anthropic has on uh some of the recent
transformers to be applied to like some
sparse expert models um some questions
we've kind of received are what is the
interplay of expert specialization with
sort of like self-attention
specialization and that's honestly
completely open um i think we were just
sort of putting this table forth to the
community to be like well we you we
started um it's not exactly what we
would have expected um but definitely
kind of like a call to
dig further and hopefully like you know
further improve things
with the
also i believe that this was oh yeah
here already in switch transformers this
ability to
uh distribute these things across
devices that comes naturally with um
with having sparse experts so sparsity
meaning in this case i only send stuff
to one or a few experts and there there
came the ability to shard this across
devices how like
how practical is this really to
like what
when would i do something like this at
what point would it become
practical and useful and the best thing
to do to communicate across devices
for my experts
yeah so really great question and i
actually think this is the reason why
the method works so well actually
so
the standard way i would say people are
doing distributed training of these
models is they have you know either
fully data parallelism which means like
you know each machine has the same set
of weights but different slices of data
or a blend of data and model parallelism
where it's like you know kind of a mix
where certain like you know cores have
sometimes different weights or sometimes
different data and then you communicate
stuff to make it you know emulate like a
full model
but
i think experts one really easy
interpretation of this is like let's say
you have a model and you know you're
using data parallelism and you have four
different machines
a really natural way to overlay experts
on this would be you just have one
expert per machine
and then yeah so this is like a really
nice interpretation because then when
you have all of your you know local data
per core you have the router weights
replicated
but then you just figure out what expert
they need to go to and then that's when
you kind of you know shuffle all the
tokens around to the machines
do all the computation and then shuffle
them back
and
this makes it really nice because then
per
machine you actually never have any more
parameters than you would have had just
with a dense transformer but now you
have experts
so it's actually like a really nice way
of kind of you know thinking about how
to design the models would be like oh
you know you have this many cores for
data parallelism just have that many
experts and that's actually a paradigm
that liam and i use a lot when designing
these models as well
and yeah i mean i think as soon as you
have this sort of like distributed model
where you're already going across
accelerators and devices
you do already have these communication
patterns right like you need to get
activations to a certain place you need
to like get gradients to a certain place
so you already have these sort of like
all reduced
communication collectives
uh
uh expert model is going to introduce
all to all communication patterns so
that can be like a more expensive thing
especially based on like your topology
and um the bandwidth between all of your
networks right between all of your
devices um but yeah so i mean this is
something you sort of have to like
kind of empirically test like okay how
how much does this
architecture kind of uh buy you in terms
of performance on your task versus the
additional cost of all to all
communication um but you you will be
communicating across devices for these
big models regardless to tram yeah
so this is a good i guess a good segue
because you can achieve these
giant models like trillions of
parameters using these these sparse
expert models because naturally i can
parallelize these experts it doesn't
cost me really much more compute because
any data point or any token only goes to
one single expert
uh
there is always a bit of the
let's say
the question of how comparable this is
to the dense models it was it was often
i don't know if this is a latent feeling
that i get from the community but people
would rather have the
175 billion gpt3 model compared to the
switch transformer even if it is
trillions of parameters
what's
is there some sort of division factor
where i could compare to a dense model
or do you think that it's an entirely
different nature of a function that's
computed here
yeah so this is a really great question
and i think there's a lot of different
ways you have to kind of look at this to
figure out if a sparse model is right
for you
so i think actually in a lot of
applications if it's like hey i want to
train the model
with the smallest memory footprint so i
can just be using it on the smallest
amount of
devices as possible a dense model will
always be better like i think on a per
parameter basis dense models are going
to be performing better so for those
types of applications i'm like yeah i
don't think it makes sense to be using
sparse models if you want to just train
the best thing that you can fit onto
your local 2gpu machine or like a 10 gpu
machine and do really kind of you know
low throughput
you know
feeding in data to this like not high or
anything like that i think sparse models
are good
where you're going to be training a
model and you're going to be hosting it
on a lot of machines and you're going to
be having like a lot of like high
throughput going through it so a lot of
queries a lot of stuff going through it
because then things can be batched
together and then the models actually
become
pretty efficient
so i think that's kind of one lens to
look at when you would want to use a
sparse uh versus dense model
and i think the kind of second lens is
that you know for a given amount of like
you know
gpu or tpu hours on like a compute
cluster what model will get you the best
performance and i think that's the lens
that we actually would spend a lot of
time looking at for like you know
pre-training models in this paper like
oh you have 512 tpu chips
and i give you you know x budget
training hours
is a dense model or sparse model going
to give you the best pre-training
performance and i think our assessment
was that yeah i think the actually the
pareto optimal model typically is a
sparse model in that in that setup
yeah and like comparing parameters
especially between a dense and a sparse
model is just you know
totally incomparable so
using like gpt3 and then like our
largest like switch transformer model uh
it's just widely different amount of
compute in our case you can't infer that
from the parameter budget um so i don't
know what the like the compute ratio was
between the two but um far different our
1.6 trillion parameter model was
actually only doing about as much
compute as a billion parameter model um
so for each token it was doing you know
roughly a billion parameters worth of
flops and you know whereas gpd3 is doing
175 billion parameters worth of flops um
so you can sort of tune this and
deepmind has sort of also tried to some
come up with like a characterization of
scaling properties uh far more like
robust than than we've been able to do
of sparse expert models and try to
come up with like you know a dense model
equivalent um so like that might be like
an interesting work to sort of like
refer to in in the future um but really
it's just like you know practically
speaking it's like okay i give you these
accelerators for this amount of time
what's like the best model um
so that that's like probably the fairest
comparison
um have you
seen this pathways paper
yes definitely it came out like how does
it how does it play into something like
this is it going to make
is it going to make this easier is it
going to make it
superfluous like how does the the sort
of
ability to schedule things
heterogeneously across devices or does
it does it uh enable new possibilities
in in the sparse expert world
yeah so great question so
so one thing to note is like okay so
typically you have dense models and a
dense model like every input will have
the same amount of compute and
parameters applied to it and sparse
models now you have the same amount of
compute but different parameters and i
think the kind of natural next step that
i think makes a lot of sense to both
liam and i is that now for each input
you have a different amount of compute
applied as well
and i think pathways is really exciting
again like you kind of mentioned for
like the heterogeneous compute where we
want to have inputs that might require
you know different parameters and also
different amounts of compute
yeah and i think you know a framework
like this is going to really open up
like a lot of really exciting um
research avenues along that direction
and i think it feels like a very natural
interpretation for kind of where our
models are headed for in the future
yeah like right now it's like our
experts are all sort of completely
homogenous they're all the same size
they do the same operations
pathways you could be like oh this is
like a recurrent expert this is a huge
expert there's a group of small experts
um you could just be
a lot more flexible in design um and
like yeah sort of like alluding to that
a little bit with um when you're looking
at the visualization it's like oh wow a
really consistent thing
are experts that want to specialize in
these like uh fill in the blank tokens
these sentinel tokens um perhaps that
might be an avenue or an area where it's
like oh let's dramatically increase the
compute here um this is oh hi cat
this is like an area where
we like a lot of extra compute could
really be helpful and there wasn't
really an effective way to do this with
the
existing infrastructures before pathways
is there is there a
um
yeah
sorry that that's
lost lost the train of thought um
explain to me a little bit how
how glam improved upon switch
transformers like what's new uh what's
exciting there
yeah so i think glam so so one also
thing to note is like there's kind of a
right now division of two different
types of model classes in like the
language modeling space i would say
so one is like these decoder only models
where you know it's just you know a
single set of parameters and it's like
you're just predicting the the next
token um
like auto aggressively and this is like
you know what gpt 3 is and this is also
the kind of architecture that glam
studies these models in
so the other class is these like encoder
decoder models like t5 this was also
g-shard this is kind of what also we
studied in switch transformer and our um
most recent work as well so i think glam
did a few things so one they really i
think pushed the scale of these models
so like while you know our original
model at switch transformer had more
parameters like glam had like much more
compute applied per token and they
studied these very extensively with
decoder only language models
and yeah i think their main comparison
point was to gpt3 as well so they were
studying a lot in the context of fushot
and like one shot evaluations whereas i
think a lot of our work actually
centered around like fine-tuning the
models
um but yeah i think glam really like
pushed the scale
of these especially in these decoder
only language models and showed that
like yeah you know you can get as good
of quality as gp3 with like you know
huge
computational training savings as well
and did a really a lot of really good
work in that space
is there a functional difference between
the sparse expert routing or anything
around this in in glam or is it mainly
uh what you what you said with decoder
only and applying more compute scaling
it up
um so actually there is a few
differences that are
more nuanced than technical um but yeah
at a high level you know there's a
routing function and they actually route
each um token to two experts
and actually there's like some of the
differences in these models comes from
like how much buffer you give each token
each expert because you know you need to
have like fixed batch sizes for all the
experts ahead of time
and so what can happen is like you can't
guarantee that like there's going to be
perfect balancing among all of the
tokens getting sent to experts so like
experts can overflow and there's this
key parameter that we call the capacity
factor that's probably the
single-handedly most important parameter
when designing a mixture of expert
models because it just has such a huge
impact on the communication costs
compute and everything like that for how
much buffer you should have and yeah i
think a big difference from glam versus
our models is they actually use like a
much larger capacity factor than we've
used in our other works um but yeah the
routing algorithm is uh is essentially
the same
that is
yeah i want to get bit more into the
into the routing algorithm in just a bit
but just to uh end this with the with
the last paper that we've uh previously
looked at uh was i write in saying that
this is much more of an
uh let's say a a general almost like a
review paper or how would you describe
it
yeah i mean i think we we tried to make
sure like we're contextualizing a lot of
the work so we try to make sure the
related work was like
pretty inclusive because i mean i think
the field's really uh
adjusted and improved a lot in the last
two years
but i would sort of characterize this
paper as fixing the two big flaws from
our first one from switch transformers
the first was these models are unstable
to train so you'd be training and then
all of a sudden the loss would just
diverge
which thwarted a lot of our issues
interestingly it doesn't seem like the
instability arises from a lot of experts
we were consistently able to train
models like our trillium parameter model
for instance with thousands of experts
never really hitting any uh unstable
sections
really kind of came from like high flops
or high computation expert models even
with like few experts those were highly
unstable and then the second thing that
this paper sort of fixed was this sort
of like poor fine-tuning quality so we
would sort of pre-train a model it would
uh show like really significant speed
ups over a dense counterpart but then
when it came time to fine-tuning say i'm
like super glue or some like other task
of interest it would just be
considerably worse um so i think this
paper was just
really trying to sort of like kind of
patch up a couple of those issues we
identified them in our first work
yeah i'm always a bit intimidated when a
paper has a table of index by itself
can you can you go this is something
that barry and i discuss it's like okay
should we break this up into multiple
papers or it should just be one because
you know this is like you know a lot of
work and you know this is like something
that we discussed like maybe in the
future we should probably be
producing like more bite-sized pieces of
work
when you when you talk about fine tuning
can you go a bit into more detail like
what was exactly the problem how did you
how did you also go about fixing it so
i'm not only interested in um you know
how did how what's the final model like
but what does the process of debugging
something like this and then
getting to an architecture or a solution
that actually works look like
yeah i mean it's sort of this like very
interesting problem of like
you want to
there there's really just like
fundamental trade-off and whenever
you're sort of doing this sort of like
large-scale work
where you want to try to understand and
characterize things at a smaller scale
understand um scaling properties
understand understand like hyper
parameter dependencies
but then you also want to be
consistently checking yourself at the
largest skills and this sort of balance
of like okay you have this much compute
you have this much time
where do you allocate it do you do a lot
of small experiments or you do a few big
experiments um it's kind of tricky
but i'd say
part of our like findings were
the first one was like okay well
characterization is we're not doing
better on fine-tuning what's the cause
and it seemed like perhaps our cause is
not that of optimization it's that of
generalization so if you scroll down um
into section four you can just click on
the link um we might be
yeah exactly
yeah so this is an example that you know
kind of supports a lot of the trends
we're seeing
on the left is a small super glue task
so this task has only 250 training
sequences so very small
and on the right is record so this has
over 100 000 training examples
we're showing
uh sparse models versus dense models um
in the two things in the two plots
blue represents the sparse trainee vowel
and you can see it just very quickly
gets to 100 and it outpaces in both
cases the small task and the large task
outpaces the dense model getting to 100
train evaluation accuracy
but when in the small task we'll see the
dense model in red actually
outperforming the ultimate performance
for the sparse model in orange whereas
for the bigger tasks the sparse model
does well and so we kind of kept seeing
this like you know overfitting issues
and a lot of this was
then led us to sort of like investigate
hyper parameters and you know some of
the hyper parameters can sort of be
adjusted in a way to
make the model like less susceptible to
overfitting so you can use like
different dropout parameterizations but
also things like um batch size and
learning rate can inject more noise
which can also be sort of like a counter
to some like overfitting properties
um so i we tried and then
sort of consistent with this like a lot
of these things were sort of like you
know more exhaustive studies at say a
billion parameter scale
we then tried to continue to sort of
like fact check this against our larger
model um and make sure that these
conclusions were holding um so i think
it was just sort of like you know the
debugging process was okay what more
precisely is going wrong and then like
what are our levers um that we can sort
of like pull in order to try to like
improve it um but you know a bit of art
and science really
you
so you is it you observed okay we are
probably overfitting because you saw the
smaller the tasks got sort of the worse
these sparse models would ultimately
perform on the validation set of those
tasks did you
and you have it's not like quite like
yeah it's not always like quite so um
easy as that but it's sort of like you
know directionally like i think we have
support of the hypothesis but it's not
like every single small task does poorly
in every large test is great yeah but
i'd say directionally it seems to be a
phenomenon we've observed
you have also a bunch of experiments
down here where you act where you
investigate uh some of these for example
dropout probabilities you also have
expert dropout probability which is one
of the questions i had in that you have
a particular architecture right with
these with these experts and when i
think about overfitting when in regular
transformers i have kind of handles i
can use adapter layers i can only
fine-tune the head and so on um did you
ever investigate maybe only fine-tuning
some of the experts like is that
keeping others constant is that ever a
thing like would that work or
or
um you know can we can we make use
somehow of the fact that we have these
different experts and they're actually
different functions
yeah great question and i think actually
if you scroll down we did a very naive
kind of version of this not where we
freeze different experts but we you know
freeze all of the experts or maybe only
train all the experts and freeze all of
the other parameters
um i would say our findings were this
were surprising
in a bad way
so
nothing nothing really worked super well
so here you can see like and this is
also we only studied this on super glue
right so it's far from exhaustive but um
yeah so one thing we tried was updating
first all of the non-mixture of expert
parameters only and that actually
performed about the same which was kind
of interesting it's like hey like
actually freezing the mixture of expert
weights like seemed to perform about as
well as just like updating the whole
model
then when we started to you know update
only the mixture of expert weights and
freeze all the other model parameters
like the performance was actually really
bad
um and there's some we still fully don't
understand what's going on here we have
like a few kind of like half-baked
hypotheses but
um yeah
then when we update only the attention
parameters things are worse and we found
a slight boost updating only the feed
forward network parameters that weren't
the mixture of expert layers but
yeah overall nothing worked that well
but yeah i think there might be some
potential really interesting things of
like hey maybe allowing only you know a
certain subset of experts to be
fine-tuned
we we did spend a little bit of time
actually studying like pruning off
experts during fine tuning
so like as for a specific fine-tuning
task if your pre-trained model has like
64 experts can you just take like a
subset of like 2 4 8 or 16 of them
um yeah and we also didn't really get
that good of signal with this as well
also to some of your recommendations
there actually would be compatible with
expert models too so
you're free to just like fine-tune like
the top um like logit layer or you could
add in adapter layers yeah we didn't do
anything like really funky like you were
suggesting like oh we're only going to
expert like update experts like 3 8 and
14 or something um
yeah my intuition is that probably
wouldn't work well but i mean i've been
proven wrong many times
um
yeah we tried some like other things
that didn't make it to this table or
these plots um
and yeah again we didn't really see like
a significant boost that said if you are
only updating like a fraction of the
parameters that you get some memory
savings um
so you know some nice things
cool uh i guess
you know there's there's almost an
infinite number of things one could try
with these things like distilling
experts like distilling multiple experts
into a single expert so you have another
expert that's again free to do some some
new tasks once you know that two experts
are converging something like i think
there's
it's really interesting right a lot of a
lot of we're adding in new experts on
the fly yeah a lot of possibilities and
that brings me a bit to yeah this this
routing function that um we we talked
about before and at the beginning
which seems to me is a really crucial
part of the
system yet as you said before uh very
often i've just seen this being
implemented quite
simplistically maybe there's a linear
transform and then a soft max or
something like this uh maybe
not even maybe there is some some sort
of a
you know you have some fixed keys for
ever all of the experts and then you're
out according to that um do you
like my intuition would be that
this could be a powerful handle on
what's you know on my performance
downstream this this routing function
especially also making this different
during inference um
you know any any number of things
doing a monte carlo research at
inference time to to be as as accurate
as possible it kind of like like alphago
or something um do you have a an idea on
what the power of the routing function
in these sparse models is and how how
does it work currently like what's the
most the latest and greatest and
how good is it
yeah so this is a really good
question actually um and something we've
actually spent a lot of time about so i
would say actually in this project
probably the thing i maybe spent the
most time with is trying out different
routing algorithms and writing
parameterizations but we ended up kind
of going with the default thing which i
also think
says something a little bit about the
results of it um
yeah so
i would say my intuition is that
the model actually works surprisingly
well with a lot of different ways you
can route
the tokens
so like you know we tried a lot of other
routing algorithms we tried making like
the routing network larger we tried like
you know some fancier ways of actually
figuring out where you should send the
token to we tried you know using
additional information of like oh when
you're routing this current
representation you have access to
whether or not like it was routed or
like where it was routed before in
previous layers
using like word embedding information
too
um
but yeah i think overall it seemed to be
you know kind of insensitive we actually
did find like one or two methods that
improve things but um they could they
could only be used in certain situations
so it was a bit um it was a bit trickier
to just like replace everything
the current routing algorithm we're
using is basically uh what the original
one was doing i think in shazir at all
in 2017 when these kind of things were
like really introduced into the lstm
language models
and i think you know our newer work
and then also glam as well we're using
these kind of routing algorithms too
yeah and also like one kind of like
detail here it's like so right now we're
sort of splitting out this little box
and we're like oh this is the router
um
it's not really an accurate
characterization it's like yes okay
you're mapping some vector into a vector
that has like the same like length as
number of experts
but if you just don't update that matrix
it still works fine right because now
just the represent like the weight
matrices below you are just sort of
adapting and just piping whatever
activation they need right if you freeze
the grade if you stop a gradient through
that then it's like catastrophically bad
um but yeah i mean i've also sort of
been surprised by the relative
insensitivity to the routing algorithm
like we've seen like you know maybe some
small boost here and there but it hasn't
been super significant
i think you'd probably have a better
sort of like a bigger significance by
actually just sort of fundamentally
changing like the architecture um
like maybe there's like
some wildly different approach for sort
of sparse models that we're not
considering maybe we're in some sort of
like local men and like these small
tweaks i'm like oh okay precisely how
are we doing this maybe doesn't matter
as much and deeplines also explored some
other kind of interesting routing
algorithms like you sort of alluded to
fixed routing algorithms where it's just
like you're not even learning they've
also tried rl based routing algorithms
and i think it had like actually similar
scaling properties so again kind of
corroborating what barrett is saying
it's just like a lot of these things
when we're kind of doing this like per
token routing
haven't really moved the needle
substantially um that's been our our
look yeah and i think yep another
important trend actually is that we when
we were experimenting with a lot of
these different routing algorithms we
actually found that they did help models
and maybe when you had like a one
billion parameter dense model-ish size
but then like as we scaled up the models
like actually a lot of the time
sometimes the differences would just
like wash away as well so it's kind of
this interesting effect of when more
scale is increased like it maybe becomes
a little bit less insensitive to some of
these decisions
yeah i was i was
yeah maybe i can totally see that that
essentially that the rest of the network
adjusts especially if everything is
trainable what i would be excited about
maybe is is to somehow at inference time
doing something smarter than because at
training time i can adjust to everything
right but at inference time
maybe there there's something that i
could do especially with regards to you
know domain shift domain adaptation
anything like this where um i could i
could tweak routing in some way but i
guess that's also
also up for for future work
so there's a little bit of this not
tweaking the routing algorithm but
tweaking the capacity factor
hyperparameter i mentioned a while ago
so that's this is basically the
parameter that's going to dictate how
many tokens are being dropped and one
cool thing you can do is you can have
some uh capacity factor during training
but then at eval time depending on if
you want to use more or less compute you
can be either dropping more or less
tokens and either kind of you know
increase or decrease the performance
which is pretty cool and the model's
actually pretty robust to having that
train from train and evaluation time so
that's actually kind of like a good
lever for like you know oh depending on
if you want to use more or less compute
during um evaluation
i think we have with a pretty good
overview now i want to get a little bit
into
um just the the future the future
prospects maybe also of this we already
talked about you know with pathways we
could have um
heterogeneous things could this be
pushed to
some sort of of limit whenever i see a
distributed system you know i
immediately think distributed maybe not
even in a data center but across
users across networks is there
applications to
um maybe
what was it called federated
some kind of some kind of federated
computing some kind of federated
learning where i could somehow
contribute with my
um maybe confidential data but i could
still contribute to a whole compute
process is there
i'm gonna i'm gonna say the the b word
is there an application for blockchain
uh distribution something like this like
have you do you think about sort of uh
the the higher degrees of distribution
here
go bare yeah go for it i mean yeah so i
mean yes me personally i haven't spent a
ton of time thinking about this but i do
think it's like very interesting and
yeah there definitely seems to be a lot
of really
you know open problems around this
especially given the growing amount of
like fragmented compute fragmented
devices like there's so much compute
around here like you know how can you
effectively
utilize all of this utilize different
you know data and stuff i think it's
like a super cool and i think it was
going to require a lot of really
interesting research because
right now the way we're currently
training these models is it's all like
synchronized lock step typically right
you're doing like oh like after each uh
batch you do these gradient you send the
gradients around and everything but like
i think actually maybe
the future of these models when you're
really you know allowing them to be
distributed across very different types
of compute and everything might actually
now introduce like asynchronous training
as kind of like the new paradigm so i
think that's like a really um exciting
space but yeah i haven't spent too much
time thinking about it personally
yeah and i think like as it would
pertain to say like blockchain or
something like i think one problem with
these expert models as designed uh in
this way are these all to all
communications
so
over this sort of like you know
decentralized like peer-to-peer network
where it's like you know nodes are like
you know really far apart inconsistent
sort of bandwidth and stuff
um
that could be really tough if sort of
your experts were sort of distributed
among like many different nodes in this
sort of like unreliable network where
nodes are kind of coming and going like
right now all our systems are in this
sort of like very
constrained fault intolerant area where
it's like oh all highly internet
workships that are highly reliable um
and then so blockchain would just have
like a whole different set of like kind
of problems that you'd have to sort of
address like unreliability and you know
some of these other areas not to say i
think you'd just like require some like
additional kind of research like just
sort of adopting the model as is i think
would um pretty poorly map on that kind
of computing infrastructure but i think
there there's something there that could
be done
is there
work on because i see these works mostly
here in nlp yet transformers kind of
taking over the rest of the world
is there work on how these
expert sparse expert transformers behave
in vision in reinforcement learning
speech whatever
yeah yeah great uh question so
absolutely actually there's been some
really good work applying these models
to like vit based
uh like image classification and stuff
and there it's actually really nice
because then you can leverage all of the
you know niceties around like people
figuring out how to get these working
really well in transformers and kind of
you know um nicely map it over as well
um yeah there's also been some good work
using these in speech as well
um
liam any other things to add on top of
that some i used to do reinforcement
learning um more full-time and some
colleagues kind of reached out about
doing like sparse expert models for rl i
haven't seen i'm not familiar with some
work um but
you know that might be sort of like
another interesting avenue but like for
sure so language vision speech
um
i don't know if there's been any video
work yet um
yeah but like high data a lot of
throughput those would be like you know
really good areas i think video would be
also really promising
yeah i really like also the i feel like
it feels very natural in these high
dimensionality spaces that you really
might want different parameters to be
applied like when you have a video like
one i think you don't want to be
applying all the same amount of compute
to every frame but then on top of that i
can see like actually you really want to
have different parameters applying to
different
you know things going on in the video
because it's just going to be like
wildly different stuff happening so yeah
i think i think i'm very excited about
these models for video as well
do you
imagine that these models will just
essentially right now they're
competition to dense models they are
they're they're competing you're
tracking pareto frontiers how much
compute how well are they doing uh
tackling
very much the same tasks do you think
this will go on like do you do you think
these models might overtake dense models
if we figure out how to handle them
correctly or is it is it more like
uh there's a killer app for each one of
them
yeah i think in oh do i go ahead
i yeah i mean i honestly think that the
future is going to be adaptive like i
don't think there's any way that like in
10 years our models are treating all
examples coming in with like the same
parameters over and over again and the
same amount of compute um it may not be
this precise sort of like sparsity
regime
or may not be the precise sort of
adaptive computation kind of like
paradigms that have been put forth but i
i view this sort of kind of work of like
sparsity adaptive computation as kind of
like inevitable like i don't think it's
going to be considered like competition
it's just going to be sort of like
integrated into a lot of like leading
models that's that's my expectation i'd
be really shocked in like 10 years we're
training like a 100 trillion parameter
dense model and it's just kind of doing
the same thing like over and over again
for no matter what comes in um just
seems really strange to me
what's the
uh the future for your particular
research like where do you see where do
you see yourself going in the next maybe
not the next paper that you haven't
published yet but uh
maybe a bit broader time scale like what
excites you and what are your next plans
here
yeah great question i mean i think the
thing that really excites me is like
what we were kind of talking about
earlier of each input getting a
different amount of compute applied like
i think right now the models are working
well for each input getting different
parameters and i think you know coupling
this with like adaptive amounts of
computation is like i think
really where i want to be spending time
thinking about in the next you know
upcoming years
is there yeah
i don't know is is you have something
like ponder there's pondernet and so on
there's these recursive architectures or
recurrent architectures that that sort
of decide themselves when to when to
exit would that be one thing or do you
simply imagine that each expert is kind
of one is the buff expert and one is the
lean expert and then the routing
function essentially takes care of the
different amount of compute
yeah i don't know this is a great
question i think
i i don't know i could see either
approach potentially working or maybe
you actually want combinations or maybe
potentially something completely new um
yeah it feels like the space is still
you know
very exciting and there's like a lot of
really interesting different verticals
being pushed so the space still feels
like you know pretty young to me
um okay last question from my side
what's the connection of this to
something like capsules i don't know if
you've ever thought about the the
connection there but
with capsules i always think this is
these abstract very abstract things very
high level ideas flying around and you
here have something like very practical
you know very on the metal thing yeah
there seems to be quite some
commonalities is there is that something
that ever came up to you or
in the two years of doing sparsely
research this is literally the first
time actually okay
i actually should be going back to that
work um i feel like um capsules like
yeah had a lot of like really
interesting conceptions um but maybe
like you're kind of alluding to it
didn't like map super well to the metal
so
maybe that sort of like hindered it's
like its use whereas this is just like
highly motivated from like an
engineering perspective um we've had
like some questions like oh what is like
the neuroscientific kind of motivation
of our work and it's like it's really
engineering kind of driven so it's like
okay what what will be fast on our
existing hardware um but yeah i will
revisit capsules and kind of see like oh
okay how could we actually map this a
little bit better to the hardware and
like you know i think that could be like
you know an interesting source of ideas
um is there any any last thing you want
to get out to viewers that they should
take away
from this work any any way that a
regular person can get into this type of
research anything like this yeah so
great question so actually one thing we
tried to show in our switch transformer
work is that these models work pretty
well even if you only have two experts
so i definitely i don't want people to
think that you know you really need a
super computer to run the models or to
you know get benefits from having
experts even having i think as little as
two experts and running models could
lead to developing really interesting
research ideas improving the performance
and everything like that so um yeah i
definitely hope that you know more
people can continue to experiment and
push forward these models
yeah and then i would say like another
interesting trend that i've been
following is
sort of in parallel to sparsity and
these like you know really large models
is the idea of like well what if we just
sort of like have the model sort of
offload and like sort of do lookups or
you know look at documents and and
retrieval type methods um i think this
is sort of like a very interesting area
and i'd love to see like kind of
head-to-head comparisons of like okay do
we want to try to encapsulate the
knowledge into parameters or do we want
to just like keep it sort of like you
know a parametric non-parametric type
thing
and we keep the information kind of
written in docs or
like what does the interplay look like
um i think that's sort of like another
really interesting avenue like kind of
comparing these things
awesome yeah it sounds really cool i'm
excited to to see what the the future of
these models bring
uh yeah barrett and william thank you so
much for being here this was a lot of
fun i hope to to see you again soon yeah
that's cool thanks for having us yeah
thanks for having us
[Music]